today's belated vlog is in seven parts
and therefore is of course my Horcrux
block Horcrux number one representing my
draw my life video this sharpie I really
wanted to say a massive thank you to
everybody who has left such fantastic
comments on my draw my life video as
understandably
I think it's probably pretty nervous
about raising it and there's a lot of
personal information that I've done and
talked about before and as I said in
that video I'm really grateful to you
everybody who has been part of the
community on this channel because you
guys are so wonderful and understanding
and supportive you say thank you very
much representing Simon's far more
talented friends this hat
bringing me right back down to wherever
are my ludicrously talented group of
friends I have three friends I'd like to
draw attention to while three groups of
friends I suppose first of all you might
have already seen this hat which you if
you're awesome will know is Jane hat I
wore this in a video which I did for
science hour where Hannah and I made
some rocket fuel in my back garden and
exploded it there's a link at the
facebook video cuz we didn't put it on
any juice just on Facebook in the
description and this hat was made for me
by one of my amazing friends Rose now
she is actually taking requests for
knitwear so if you would like one of
these then I suggest that you get on her
tumblr which is in the description and
contact her if you'd like to get
anything knitted for you and I think you
should because along with Rose has also
really lovely person sings with me
magical so you know I'm biased next I
want you to open your ears for the next
18 seconds
that's a little snippet of a mash-up of
cheating by John Newman and over the
Misty Mountains from The Hobbit
soundtrack which was by fantastic his
hands in Greek in from Exeter cool
semitone now they're an all-male a
cappella group and they just released an
EP and that is part of one of the
trackers on the EP so if you like the
sound of that then check out the link in
the description and be amazed I love
doing this I'm like a cheerleader for
all my friends go Rams go semitone go
Ryan palet mention Ryan yet mother and
Ryan is a friend of mine from Oxford who
is currently doing his fourth year in
physics and two interesting facts about
Ryan one he is one of the last 100
candidates to be considered for a manned
mission to Mars as part of the
month-long program and the second
interesting thing is that he started a
vlog series about his master's project
which is on planetary science so it's
kind of a little bit similar to what I
do but he's got a vlog series and he's
got his own channel link in description
link on the screen check him out do you
teach it by the way this is actually
weird I'm wearing a t-shirt that I
designed this is for mrs. Warren a
cappella groups cause well representing
my work the Sword of Gryffindor so
what's actually been going really well
recently I've been doing my first forays
into the world of teaching I gave a
lecture the other day which was on the
stratosphere as part of a climate change
which is the first time I'm spoken for
an hour and I could have make the
subjects like to a scientific audience I
guess I mean it's undergraduates but
it's still that's basically a full-blown
teaching which was surprisingly fun
actually I really quite enjoy doing it
and I've got another one coming up on
the climate of Mars in two weeks time
apart from that though the things which
I'm meant to be doing
perhaps your research so I think the
last time I talked to you we were
looking at temperature anomalies in the
atmospheric column above the pole and
basically the point that we've got to
now is I'm now
isolating different modes of
variabilities there's the term really
for pressure as you look through the
atmosphere we have these really violent
events caused sudden stratospheric
warming so I have to teach myself this
technique called principal components
analysis and I'm now sort of isolated a
signal and I'm now actually going back
and looking physics and trying to
explain why we have a sir
pressure a type of pressure signal you
know why the graph is the shape it is so
now's when the physics comes back into
it and I'm quite looking forward to
actually using my degree that the videos
which aren't coming up anymore
Daniel boring cliff sadly the file which
I had the save file for the Kerbal space
program but the YouTube space program
has now corrupted I'm gonna vary from
the game it just crashes so
unfortunately it looks like I'm not
gonna be doing a more careful videos
which is a really big shame because I
really enjoy doing them and I'm pretty
sorry don't worry that couldn't be part
of the program because I know that I had
about 50 different people who wants to
be involved I'm really really sorry I
quite like to do some more gaming stuff
in the future though so possibly watch
this space for upcoming videos Daniel
Radcliffe now this is much more
interesting so I mentioned early that I
did a lecture on the stratosphere now
what I'm thinking of doing is splitting
that up that was a full hour I'm
basically thinking of splitting the
content of that up into a small youtube
series where basically give you an
introduction to my field and it's more
of an in-depth discussion than the sort
of hand waving stuff I've done so far if
you'd be interested in that then comment
down below I'm also thinking of doing a
video on why I turned vegetarian for
length three years ago and I actually
have been vegetarian since then making
worthwhile use of this channel rather
than just me talking to the camera about
doing video games lastly we are
hopefully gonna be doing another
livestream when I say we I mean Jamie
Mills and I I know he's interested
Jake is always in the middle of term
time and he is currently preparing for
jail break which is a fantastic charity
event which happens every year if you
don't know what that is gonna check out
his channel now well if you don't know
who Jamie is so if you don't know Jay
yes no if you don't know who Jake is
check his channel out now if you don't
even check out their channels this that
section is confusing now what I was
trying to say is we're going to be doing
a live stream I know Jamie is up for it
Jake is busy I don't know about Sally
but she's not even busy as well if you
would like them to do another live
stream with Jamie and I then hassle them
on Twitter and leave coins in their
videos because I really love to do
another live stream that's so much fun
to do Horcrux number six septima vector
professor of Erath man see but
ultimately it hasn't escaped my
attention that this child has
thousand subscribers and that's crazy we
now have I think more people subscribe
to my channel there are people in my
hometown I mean now I'm just at videos
like this I upload videos where I talk
to the camera about what I do and most
of you came here because the Oxbow
project and that's what I did I just
talk to a camera about what I was doing
with my life and now there are 15,000
people who are interested in that but
all I can say is thank you I mean I I
really need to start making more serious
content for this channel like I want to
try and do that with the stratosphere
videos because you guys have been so
fantastic and supporting and as a
community I think you deserve best
possible videos and I'm gonna try my
very best to do that so thank you very
much for investing in your click in the
hints coming to my channel horcrux
number seven the me and lastly I am
probably going to be going to Oxford in
the week of 23rd of March so that's the
last week of March to do some filming
for some Peters but if you're in Oxford
and you fancy possibly meeting up if
there's enough interest we could always
organize meeting in I don't know
bachelor square or something and just
sort of having a bit of saying a bit of
a saying hi session
I shouldn't meeting up with the Ox
loggers anyway so maybe maybe we can
combine the two ah sure maybe it'd be
nice to get people to say hello to them
as well so if you're interested in
you're in Oxford then you know you know
down there the comments section that's
actually it this is probably a really
quick vlog like from bystanders like I'm
used to talking for like 20 minutes not
like yes I suppose you can talk about
the inner workings of this perfectly
what people are interested in on YouTube
but this is actually gone really quickly
this is probably gonna be way too short
sorry if you were expecting something
longer not the first time said that
other videos people thanks for watching
guys and I'll be seeing you very soon